- [Narrator] This man rubbing shoulders
with the likes of Natalie
Portman, Paul McCartney
and Rihanna is French business
mogul Bernard Arnault.
While he might not be as
recognizable as those three,
he's got more money than
all of them combined.
Arnault is the world's richest person
with a net worth of $191
billion at the start of 2023.
- He is one of the most important
businessmen in the world,
certainly the most important
in France right now.
- [Narrator] He is the CEO
of LVMH Moët Hennessy Louis Vuitton,
which is basically the
first word in luxury.
In addition to Louis
Vuitton, the conglomerate
includes brands such as Dior, Tiffany's,
and Belvedere Vodka.
- Luxury for for me is
how can you create desire?
- [Narrator] He's been in
charge of LVMH since 1989
and all of his children
have powerful roles within the business.
Here's Bernard Arnault built his wealth
and how he plans to keep
it under family control.
(playful music)
(paparazzi chatting)
The richest person in the
world isn't a tabloid mainstay
or red carpet regular,
even if he is seen on the front row
at his brands' fashion shows.
- He's a guy who is somewhat shy.
He's even maybe a tiny bit awkward.
There's a saying, which gets
repeated to me constantly
by French billionaires
and French CEOs, which is
(Nick speaking in French)
which basically means to live happily,
you have to live hidden.
- [Narrator] The beginning
of the Arnault empire starts
with an acquisition, which
would become something
of a modus operandi for
him over the next 30 years.
In 1984, he took over
Boussac, the holding company
that owned French fashion
house Christian Dior.
- Christian Dior is maybe
the most recognizable
and the most well-known
fashion name in the world.
- [Narrator] He sold off pretty much all
of the group's brands but Dior,
and pulled it out of bankruptcy.
In the late '80s,
Dior's revival helped
Arnault a massive stake
in the recently founded LVMH,
of which he soon became
the majority shareholder,
CEO and chairman.
Over 30 years and several
acquisitions later,
LVMH now includes 75 brands,
covering wine, jewelry,
hotels and fashion.
The European company has also expanded
into China and the US
where Arnault once joined
then President Donald Trump at the opening
of a Louis Vuitton factory in Texas.
- He's a great gentleman,
a great businessman
and he's really an artist.
To me, Bernard is an artist
and what he's done is incredible.
- [Narrator] The luxury giant now
has a market value of nearly $438 billion
and revenue last year
was around $86 billion.
These results have
boosted Arnault's wealth
and put him above the likes
of big tech billionaires such
as Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos.
While those men have seen
their company shares drop
in recent months, LVMH's share price
is up over 165% since
lows in March of 2020.
Though the stock market
is apparently not something
Arnault pays attention to.
(Bernard speaking in French)
- [Narrator] That price
boost was thanks to a surge
and demand for luxury
goods during the pandemic
when affluent shoppers were
stuck at home flush with cash.
And more recently, China's loosening
of strict COVID-19 rules.
The country is one of the luxury
industry's biggest markets.
- Bernard Arnault himself
has a ton of legitimacy
because he built up this
company from scratch.
He built this empire
through several battles.
He's obviously involved
in all the key aspects of the business.
- [Narrator] Also involved in
key aspects of the business
are his five children who are often seen
with him at brand events.
Let's meet the family.
Arnault married his first
wife, Anne Dewavrin, in 1973
and they had two children,
Delphine and Antoine.
Delphine is the newly minted
CEO of Christian Dior,
while her younger brother, Antoine,
is CEO of the family holding company.
After divorcing Anne, Arnault
married Helene Mercier
and had three more children.
Alexandre holds an executive
vice president position
at Tiffany's, the American
jeweler LVMH took over in 2021.
Frederic is CEO of watchmaker Tag Heuer,
and Jean heads up marketing development
for Louis Vuitton watches.
(Bernard speaking in French)
- [Narrator] The Arnaults
own more than 97% of Dior,
which in turn owns 41% of LVMH.
The family also owns close
to 7% of LVMH directly.
On top of that,
they have total voting
rights of more than 60%.
- So essentially what the Arnaults
and what Bernard Arnault himself decides
goes in that company.
- [Narrator] And Arnault has taken steps
to ensure his family retains
control over the empire.
Last year, LVMH voted to raise
the age limit of its CEO,
meaning the 73-year-old
Arnault could remain
in charge until he's 80, if he wishes.
He also changed the structure
of the family holding company.
- The children will each have
a 20% stake in this structure
and they can't sell
their shares for 30 years
and it essentially will keep the shares
in the family even beyond that.
And it's one of the kind
of favorite pastimes in
Parisian business circle
to kind of watch his children
and track their progress
with a view to succession.
- [Narrator] Arnault has not
publicly named a successor
but whoever it is will inherit a company
that has successfully
navigated the pandemic
amid concerns for the
future of the industry.
High inflation and the war in Ukraine
have prompted estimates of a slowdown
in luxury good sales in 2023.
And in China, a recent wave
of COVID infections means
life there remains disrupted.
Economists also haven't
ruled out a global recession.
For now though at least,
the luxury market's wealthy
customers seem happy
to keep spending.
- The luxury goods industry
has been a good one for investors
in part because global
wealth every year is rising.
And so more and more people are coming
into the luxury goods market each year
and that's obviously good for
LVMH, for Bernard Arnault,
and for people selling luxury goods.
(playful music)